[Music]
today's question comes from anthony in
south carolina
our household income is 190 000 and our
only debts are a 1500 car loan and our
mortgage we have about one and a half
months income in our emergency fund i
want to accelerate building this up and
save cash for a new car to replace the
11 year old family car
my wife thinks we need to find a better
credit card that offers points and
rewards and pay it off every month a
friend of hers pays for all of their
family vacations this way and she thinks
we are quote missing out on the benefits
even if the math works and this is true
the human behavior component is too big
a factor to ignore and i don't want to
entertain this how can i convince her
that we will serve our finances better
by avoiding this we do well enough
financially that we should be avoiding
any new debt altogether and building
wealth not gaming credit card companies
for vacations
a lot of wisdom here from anthony he
gets it i don't even know if there's a
question here well the question is how
do i convince my wife she is not on
board
with this plan so do you have like you
did you did an episode on your show do
you have a
like a
two or three
bullet points that you can pass along to
a friend my when somebody asks me this
like you know they find out i work here
and they're like all right bro but
seriously like come on bro the thing i
always go back to is i love southwest i
fly southwest whenever i can they are
not my friend they are not looking out
for me they are trying to run a business
that makes a bunch of money and so when
they hand me something that they say is
for free
i have to instinctively know it's not
it's just costing somebody something
whether it's those who are have
struggled with behavior issues or and
that's me
whenever somebody gives me free points
for this free it they're not doing that
because they're altruistic right that's
always my default yeah there's gonna
come out in the wash somewhere the cost
here so on the credit card rewards
episode we did on the fine print the
podcast that you're talking about i
interviewed an ex-employee at capital
one okay and she told me they run
thousands and thousands of experiments
on humans to figure out what's going to
get them to spend more right and so what
they found is hey instead of it being
cash back we should make it points
because then you go i have 100 000
points i'm winning oh that's a hundred
dollars whoops
and oh i can only use it on these
certain dates and these certain flights
and i can only go to boise in july and
so there's all kinds of stipulations
with points shout out to boise love you
guys big fans
but there's always going to be a trap
and if you think you're winning that's
what they want you to think yeah they
want you to think man i'm really
sticking it to them i'm making so much
money off of american express and
discover card
and what i found is you are the best
cash back program that exists
when you do a budget when you get out of
debt and you stay out of debt you can
fund your own trips without having to
hope that you have enough points and
that you did the offer at the right time
and you spent enough money to hit the
reward incentive program goodness that's
exhausting
what a tiring way to live to keep up
like that so one thing i would tell you
anthony listen together to that episode
of the fine print on credit card rewards
and we equated it to chuck e cheese you
go in with ten dollars you get some
coins you have some fun playing the
games you get 45 tickets and you think
man we really crushed it and then you go
and you get a sticky hand because that's
all you can afford it's that sticky hand
cost you ten dollars you can't afford
the boom box up on the top shelf that's
seven thousand dollars to earn enough
tickets to get the boom box and so
you're you're not gonna win from this
and like you're saying john it does come
down to behavior it comes down to who is
benefiting from this and who is the one
paying for these rewards
is it the single mom who can't afford to
pay her credit card bill so she's stuck
with interest and fees that funded my
vacation
maybe is it a broken system and a toxic
money culture and company that's funding
this i don't want that either that's the
part that got me is ultimately um when i
lived with with a credit card that that
had points i was super diligent right i
was paranoid about getting back into
debt so i was super diligent this is
before i came here
and when i occurred to me oh
if they're not making money specifically
off me
it's somebody on the margins who has
been sucked into this deal to try to
make rent yeah to try to feed their kids
and they're funding my quote unquote
free vacation and i couldn't sleep with
that i want out of that game completely
right i want all all hooks out of that
system i don't want to contribute to
somebody else hurting i don't dude i'm
just going to pay for my vacations man
well here's the hilarious part they make
190 000
if you can't save up for a 10 000 car
you suck at money management yeah
there's some serious issues you can
never out earn your stupidity at that
point right if you have a fifteen
hundred dollar car loan pay it off
yesterday with the emergency fund you
guys are doing things out of order here
i think if you did it in order you'd
feel the progress you'd feel the
momentum and then you go all right the
car loans paid off let's rebuild this
emergency fund we have financial peace
we have a foundation now the world is
our oyster we can save up and pay for
that vacation we can get the new car
three months from now or but we need
some delayed grants
yeah you can do that real real quick so
it's a great question though it's hard
to get spouses to come together and
agree on something like this so that's
why financial peace university is so
powerful it gives us common language
shared goals and we go all right it's
not just me against you now it's oh
millions of people have done it this way
and that works maybe let's listen to
that so i had a guy named dr lane norton
on my show the other day talking about
exercise and we kept you know he's one
of the best in the world when it comes
to nutrition and exercise
ultimately he passed along the same
wisdom that i've heard over and over
which is every there's so many gadgets
there's so many late night things
there's so many
what if it curtis ray's out in the world
there's so many people selling you a
hack to a thing
and it's like what's the best workout i
can do the one you'll just do
every day the one you'll just be
consistent with three times a week five
times a week six times whatever the
thing is
just be consistent and if you can't show
up and do five reps
do three right show up and keep showing
up and over time you'll be fine and that
same principle works here i think we get
so out of whack and what's to this and
that stop playing games just be
consistent over time don't get in bed
with some of these people that are
hurting other people just make it
consistent make it simple and just keep
going right and that's money that's
fitness that's your mental health that's
relationships that's conversations with
your spouse it's just the same
principles be consistent and just show
up and show up